ganz wichtige Entscheidung in der Nacht
in New York in der Vollversammlung der
Vereinten Nationen Abstimmung darüber ob
die Welt die neuesten russischen
annektionen von vier großen
ukraine-regionen für völkerrechtswidrig
hält und das Ergebnis ist glasklar fast
die ganze Welt zeigt Putin da die rote
Karte
die Welt isoliert Russland kapselt sich
deutlich ab mit dieser Abstimmung
143 von 193
UN-Mitgliedstaaten sind gegen das Land
des kriegstreibers eine klare Botschaft
an den krimml-chef die
UN-Vollversammlung das größte Gremium
der Vereinten Nationen sie verurteilt
Putins Landraub die Annexionen Russlands
Einverleibung von vier ukrainischen
Regionen völkerrechtswidrig nur fünf
Stimmen für Russland Putins Bande an der
Seite des Diktators Syrien Nicaragua
Nordkorea und Belarus 35 Nationen
enthalten sich darunter Russlands
strategisch wichtigster Partner China
das Ergebnis übersteigt die
küstenprognosen Moskau international
isoliert
und weiter dabei Bild live unser Bild
Reporter Paul ronsheimer in der Ukraine
der von dort aus dieser Abstimmung
natürlich verfolgt hat wir können doch
mal ein bisschen tiefer reinschauen dort
in diese Liste die wir gerade noch mal
sehen aus der Vollversammlung also die
fünf die noch ja auf der Seite Putins
stehen Russland inklusive die haben wir
genannt es lohnt noch mal auf die zu
gucken die jetzt auch gegen Putin
gestimmt haben nämlich auch Erdogan auch
die Türkei auch Länder wie Saudi Arabien
beispielsweise das heißt es ist richtig
einsam mittlerweile um Putin
absolut geil und Erdogan ist das glaube
ich ein entscheidender Faktor denn
Erdogan hat versucht sich in den
vergangenen Monaten immer wieder neutral
zu verhalten hat auch mit Wladimir Putin
verhandelt hat aber dennoch immer gesagt
auch von Beginn an das er gegen diesen
Krieg ist und dass das was putinen getan
hat eine
illegale Annektion war ein illegales
Referendum was jetzt hier in den
vergangenen Wochen passiert ist aber es
zeigt wo die Richtung hingeht das ist
kein Vergleich mehr zu dem was wir nach
2014 also der Annexion der Krim erlebt
haben es ist viel weitreichender viel
entschiedener und viel entschlossener
und da geht es nicht nur um Symbolik
denn am Ende ist auch die Frage woher
kommt woher bekommt Wladimir Putin zum
Beispiel noch bestimmte Teile für seine
Waffen bestimmte Chips bestimmte Dinge
die er dafür braucht und da spielt immer
wieder auch China eine Rolle der spielt
Indien eine Rolle das sind Länder die
immer noch etwas wackeln kann man sagen
aber dennoch ist eben der das Zeichen
ganz klar auf der Welt das ist nicht zu
akzeptieren das schauen wir uns noch mal
auf der Weltkarte an die wir gerade
schon mal kurz gezeigt haben Paul das
ist die Karte auf der ganz klar wird
dass die Welt nicht gespalten ist
sondern tatsächlich Blau-Gelb ist also
Ukrainisch ist eine ganz Amerika ganz
der Norden sowieso aber auch die größten
Teile des Südens Amerika die caragua
fällt daraus das einzige Land das dann
auf der Seite für Russland gestimmt hat
in Afrika haben sich einige enthalten
noch das sehen Sie an diesen weißen
Flecken auf der Karte und der große
weiße Fleck dann im Osten ist eben China
dass sich enthalten hat und auch Indien
dass sich enthalten hat aber ansonsten
die Welt tatsächlich Blau-Gelb gegen die
ganz wenigen roten Flecken die
russischen Flecken
und das ist das was natürlich Wladimir
Putin Rasen macht und das ist auch etwas
so mit obwohl nicht gerechnet hat Kai zu
Beginn des Krieges man muss da ja noch
mal erinnern am 24 Februar also hier in
Kiews los ging dachte er würde ja
einmarschieren es würde kaum Gegenwehr
geben die Leute würden sogar noch
irgendwie applaudieren da könnte sich
Russland einverleiben und dann gäbe es
aus der internationalen Welt eh keine
Konsequenzen für ihn zumindest nicht so
harte das hatte er noch im Kopf aus 2014
dann kam es anders die Ukraine haben
sich massiv gewehrt und der Westen sehr
entscheidend hat die Ukraine viel mehr
unterstützt als Russland das erwartet
hat und das führt zu dem Ergebnis was
wir momentan haben an der Front dass die
Ukraine vorankommt langsam aber stetig
das Gebiete bereits zurückerobert wurden
im Osten und auch Teile im Süden und das
jetzt die große Frage ist wie lange muss
dieser Krieg noch dauern aus der Ukraine
ist die Antwort klar der Krieg
Vorbeigehen wenn Putin Weg ist das ist
das was man hier immer wieder sagt das
wiederum ist auch nicht absehbar also
die Fronten sind sehr verhärtet danke an
unseren BILD-Reporter paronzheimeride
[Musik]